ein Video und die Antwort auf alle
Fragen müssen wir Angst vor einem
Blackout haben wie umweltschädlich sind
Solarzellen überhaupt genug
Energiespeicher sind überall Windräder
stehen
und wer beantwortet diese ganzen Fragen
nun manche Sachen kann man einfach
googeln klar das dachten wir zumindest
aber wir haben echt so viele Fakten und
Zusammenhänge in diesem Video für die
wir wochenlang recherchieren mussten
weil es einfach noch niemand irgendwo
gesammelt zusammengetragen hat teilweise
mussten wir zwei Tage lang recherchieren
um einen Absatz schreiben zu können
unsere Autorin ist wahnsinnig geworden
aber das Thema ist wichtig die
Umstellung auf erneuerbare Energien ist
die umfassendste Umgestaltung unserer
Infrastruktur seit Jahrzehnten und sie
ist eine der Lösungen für das größte
Problem unserer Zeit die Klimakrise
daher wollen wir hier versuchen in einem
Video fast alles zu klären ob die
Energiewende möglich ist und was wir
dafür brauchen wo die Probleme sind und
wie wir sie lösen von den Rohstoffen
über die Stromnetze und Strom Speicher
bis hin zum Recycling drei Monate
Recherche über 100 Quellen die wir euch
alle transparent unten verlinkt haben
und zahlreiche Expertengespräche später
habt ihr nun das Ergebnis vor euch also
holt euch eine riesige Portion Popcorn
macht es euch gemütlich los geht's
die Forschung der Deutschen
Energieagentur hat ergeben das mit
Elektrifizierung alleine die
Energiewende nicht zu stemmen ist denn
noch gibt es keine ausreichend großen
Speichermedien für Windkraft oder
Solarenergie es ist
der müssen dreimal besser sein in allen
Bereichen
[Musik]
also erst einmal ganz wichtig wie viel
Energie müssen wir eigentlich mit
erneuerbaren Energien erzeugen was ist
die Zielmarke die Antwort genauso viel
wie jetzt liegt nah ist aber falsch 2021
haben wir in Deutschland rund 3.400
Terawattstunden an Primärenergie
gebraucht aber Achtung Primärenergie ist
nicht gleich genutzte Energie und erst
recht nicht gleich Strom sie teilt sich
folgendermaßen auf da ist wie ihr seht
auch Energie mit dabei die wir in Form
von zum Beispiel Abwärme oder bei
Umwandlungsprozessen verschwenden diese
verlustreichen Prozesse sind bei
erneuerbaren Energien deutlich niedriger
wo wir nicht erst durch Verbrennung von
fossilen Energieträgern Wasserdampf
erzeugen müssen der dann wiederum eine
Turbine antreibt die dann erst Strom
erzeugt
unser Primärenergiebedarf wird also in
Zukunft weniger und singt tatsächlich
sogar bereits seit 2006 für den
Strombedarf der in Zukunft einen großen
Teil unseres Energiebedarfs ausmachen
wird sieht die Rechnung aber anders aus
dadurch dass immer mehr digitalisiert
wird brauchen wir in Zukunft zum
Beispiel immer mehr Strom dadurch dass
viele Energieverbraucher von Gas Öl und
Co auf Strom umstellen steigt unser
Bedarf ebenfalls und zwar gewaltig als
Beispiel in Zukunft werden immer mehr
Autos mit Strom statt Benzin oder Diesel
fahren die Industrie soll ebenfalls
immer mehr auf Strom umstellen und auch
Wärmepumpen als Heizung für unsere
Häuser werden mit Strom betrieben das
ist alles super denn Strom können wir
aus regenerativen also erneuerbaren
Quellen generieren während fossile
Brennstoffe endlich sind und immer CO2
verursachen werden aber diese Umstellung
ist dennoch ein großer Treiber des
Strombedarfs auf der anderen Seite der
Rechnung steht dass unsere Geräte immer
effizienter werden und unsere Häuser
immer besser isoliert werden sollen
letzteres würde vor allem unseren
Wärmeenergiebedarf enorm senken außerdem
sinkt unser Ressourcenverbrauch
insgesamt darauf kommen wir ganz am Ende
nochmal zu sprechen aber auch das senkt
unseren Bedarf am Ende ergibt sich
daraus folgendes die Bundesregierung
schätzt dass unser brutto Stromverbrauch
bis 2030 bis dahin wollen wir 80%
erneuerbaren Strom haben um rund 27 bis
32 Prozent im Vergleich zu 2021 steigen
wird es wären dann 715 bis 740
Terawattstunden insgesamt so ganz genau
weiß das aber natürlich noch keiner denn
das alles hängt von sehr vielen Annahmen
bei den Berechnungen ab wie viel zum
Beispiel elektrifiziert wird wie viel
Wasserstoff wir importieren oder selbst
in Deutschland herstellen werden und wie
viel effizienter wir werden ihr seht
schon das ist alles sehr komplex
in jedem Fall wäre es gut wenn wir den
Strombedarf so weit wie möglich senken
würden denn diesen zukünftigen Bedarf
müssen wir jetzt noch mal verdoppeln bis
verdreifachen wenn es darum geht wie
viele Windräder und Solaranlagen wir
brauchen wir müssen theoretisch viel
mehr produzieren können als wir
normalerweise verbrauchen das klingt
paradox ist aber logisch sagen wir mal
wir bauen so viele solar- und
Windanlagen dass sie bei voller
Auslastung genauso viel Energie
produzieren wie wir maximal benötigen
jetzt wird der Wind aber zum Beispiel
nur ein Drittel so doll dir könnte und
die Sonne scheint auch nicht das heißt
wir müssten das Dreifache von dem was
wir brauchen theoretisch produzieren
können damit wir auch an Tagen mit nur
einem Drittel Wind genug Energie haben
okay und was heißt das jetzt ganz
konkret in Zahlen wie viele Wind und
Photovoltaikanlagen brauchen wir
bevor wir da tiefer einsteigen hier drei
technische Dinge die ab jetzt immer
wieder auftauchen werden erstens Energie
ist nicht gleich Strom hier seht ihr die
vier großen Bereiche der
Energieerzeugung die Stromerzeugung den
Verkehr die Gebäude also insbesondere
das Heizen oder auch Klimaanlagen und
die Industrie beim Punkt Stromerzeugung
konnten wir in Deutschland bereits gute
Fortschritte in Richtung
Klimaneutralität machen auch weil das
Ersetzen von Fossil erzeugtem Strom
durch Strom aus Solarzellen und
Windrädern einfacher umsetzbar ist bei
den anderen drei Bereichen gab es in den
letzten Jahren aber leider weniger
Fortschritte zweitens wir nutzen häufig
Zahlen aus 2020 oder 2021 weil
aktuellere Zahlen teilweise einfach noch
nicht verfügbar sind und lasst euch
nicht davon irritieren dass manche
Studienziele bis 2050 ausrechnen und
andere bis 2045 das liegt daran dass die
Zielmarke für die Klimaneutralität in
Deutschland in den letzten Jahren von
2050 auf 2045 gesenkt wurde was geiles
je nachdem von wann eine Studie ist
arbeitet sie in ihren Berechnungen noch
mit der alten oder schon mit der neuen
Jahreszahl und drittens wenn wir von
Szenarien sprechen beruht das auf
Modellierungen von Forschenden die haben
dann verschiedene Zukunftsszenarien
durchgespielt und kommen so teilweise zu
unterschiedlichen Ergebnissen wenn ihr
mehr zu den Szenarien wissen wollt die
wir zitieren könnt ihr einfach in die
Nummer die währenddessen unten links am
Bildschirmrand eingeblendet wird im
Quellen Dokument nachgucken das in der
Videobeschreibung verlinkt ist da findet
ihr jede unserer Aussagen durch Studien
oder Experten belegt so jetzt kann es
weitergehen also wie viele Anlagen
brauchen wir um genug Strom zu
produzieren als Zielmarke für den Ausbau
der Windenergie an Land bis 2030 gibt
die Bundesregierung 115 Gigawatt an
erfahrungsgemäß Verhalten dieser
Ausbauziele aber schneller als tiktok
Trends der Strombedarf der diesen Ziel
zugrunde liegt ist beispielsweise
bereits nach oben korrigiert worden was
gut ist die Bundesregierung hat da lange
zu noch nicht gestapelt bis zur
Klimaneutralität gibt es leider noch
keine offizielle Zielmarke die benötigte
windenergie-leistung an Land und auf See
zusammen beziffert das
Fraunhofer-Institut ISE bis 20150 auf
rund 250 Gigawatt andere Studien bewegen
sich im Bereich von 121 bis 291 Gigawatt
an installierter Leistung bis 2045 je
nachdem welche Annahmen man trifft im
Vergleich zu 2020 fehlen uns da nur rund
200 Gigawatt wie viele Windräder das
sein werden das weiß leider keiner denn
wir wissen nicht wie effizient sie dann
sein werden aber zur Fläche da können
wir schon was sagen die Bundesregierung
hat sich zum Ziel gesetzt zwei Prozent
der Landesfläche in Deutschland für
Windräder auszuweisen um den Bedarf zu
decken also circa 13 mal die Größe des
Bodensees und hier kommt jetzt das nicht
ganz unwichtige aber viel zu unbekannte
Detail diese zwei Prozent beziehen sich
auf die Fläche des Windrades inklusive
der Abstandsflächen innerhalb dieses
Radius können aber ganz hervorragend
noch zum Beispiel für grasen oder es
kann Weizen wachsen die Fläche ist also
keineswegs komplett verloren von diesen
zwei Prozent von Deutschland werden also
vermutlich wiederum nur zwei Prozent
also insgesamt 0,04 Prozent tatsächlich
von Windrädern bebaut sein das sind dann
nach unserer Rechnung nur noch ein
Viertel vom Bodensee für alle Windräder
zusammen
2020 waren nur 0,7 bis 0,85% der
Landesfläche für den Bau von Windrädern
ausgewiesen das Problem steckt hier auch
ein bisschen im Föderalismus denn solche
Flächen auszuweisen ist Ländersache und
jedes Land hat natürlich irgendwo seine
eigenen Regeln doch das könnte bald
besser werden bis 2032 sollen die Länder
insgesamt 2% der Fläche ausgewiesen
haben das hat der Bundestag im Frühling
diesen Jahres im Gesetzesform festgelegt
kommen wir nun zu einem strahlenden
Beispiel nachhaltiger Energielieferanten
der Sonne für die Solarenergie gibt die
Bundesregierung als Ausbauziel 215 GB
bis 2030 an für 2050 gibt das Fraunhofer
Institut 414 GB im Szenario Referenz an
hierfür fehlen uns aktuell noch rund 342
GB aber auch hier gilt es lässt sich
flächenmäßig viel zusammenlegen
Solarpanels können auf Hausdächern
Weiden und noch viel mehr installiert
werden und verbrauchen so ebenfalls
weniger eigene Fläche und eine Firma aus
Dresden arbeitet an Solarfolien die
biegbar sind und viel weniger wiegen so
dass man sie einfach an Häuser Seiten
oder Garagen kleben kann die Fabrik in
der diese Folien hergestellt werden habe
ich letztens besucht und durfte sogar
mit dem CEO sprechen das Video dazu
kommt nächsten Sonntag also abonniert
gerne dr Watson und aktiviert die Glocke
und benachrichtigt zu werden damit ihr
dieses Video nicht verpasst und
natürlich gibt es noch mehr erneuerbare
Energiequellen als Solar nochmal zur
Erinnerung Energie ist nicht gleich
Strom hier geht es jetzt auch um
Wärmeenergie Kraftstoffe und dergleichen
2021 führt die Biomasse diese Rangliste
der erneuerbaren Energieträger in
Deutschland mit 55% an gefolgt von 24%
Windenergie und nur 11% Photovoltaik
weight watch Biomasse who the [ __ ] ist
Biomasse und warum redet da fast niemand
drüber wenn das doch so viel ausmacht
nun herzlich willkommen zum Thema
Wärmeenergie über das insgesamt viel zu
wenig gesprochen wird
[Musik]
Biomasse ist im Endeffekt alles was man
verbrennen kann das entweder nachwächst
oder fortlaufend von irgendwelchem Leben
produziert wird organische Abfälle zum
Beispiel oder Holz diese Biomasse wird
sowohl für Wärme als auch Strom und
Treibstoff verwendet und um zu verstehen
warum sie so wichtig ist muss man
ziemlich viele verschiedene Zahlen
zusammentragen Biomasse macht nämlich
85% der Erneuerbaren Wärmequellen aus
Wärme kommt aber erst zu 16,5% aus
erneuerbaren Energiequellen allerdings
macht Wärmeenergie 2018 ungefähr 75% des
gesamten Energieverbrauchs der Industrie
aus rund 60 Prozent des Gewerbes
Handels- und Dienstleistungen und sogar
um die 90% des Energieverbrauchs der
Haushalte der Energiebedarf für Wärme
war 2017 so groß wie für Strom und
Verkehr zusammen und wenig von viel
ergibt dann eben doch wieder viel
rechnet man dann noch den
biomassenanteil an der verkehrsenergie
und der Strom Energie hinzu dann kommt
man auf die 55
ist Biomasse also unser heimlicher
Superheld
vermutlich nicht denn sie ist umstritten
aktuell stammt ein großer Teil von ihr
aus Anbau Biomasse also Pflanzen die nur
dafür angebaut werden um sie für die
Energieproduktion wieder zu verbrennen
oder zu verehren das hat derart viele
negative Auswirkungen auf das
Gesamtsystem Klima dass es nach dem
Willen des Umweltbundesamtes gänzlich
gestoppt werden sollte was hingegen
schon Chancen hat ist die Verarbeitung
von zum Beispiel Gülle und anderen
Abfällen die ja sowieso anfallen
insgesamt wird die Menge an Biomassen
Energie aber womöglich zurückgehen
und es gibt neben Biomasse noch eine
wichtige unbekannte über die kaum
gesprochen wird die Geothermie im
Grundprinzip beruht darauf zwischen
wenigen Metern und bis zu 5 km tief in
die Erde zu bohren dort eine Flüssigkeit
von der natürlichen Erdwärme erwärmen zu
lassen und sie wieder nach oben zu holen
mit dieser Wärmeenergie lässt sich nun
Strom herstellen und noch viel wichtiger
Häuser heizen die Umwelteinflüsse der
Geothermie sind dabei relativ gut
beherrschbar sorgen beziehen sich auf
Erschütterungen des Bodens und die
umliegende Trinkwasserqualität bei sehr
tiefen Bohrungen für große Anlagen diese
Effekte sollen aber wenn man sich an die
gesetzlichen Rahmenbedingungen hält
beherrschbar sein so dass
Umweltbundesamt so könnte Geothermie uns
helfen unseren wahnsinnigen
Wärmeenergiebedarf zu decken ebenso wie
die sogenannte Kraft wärmekopplung
hierbei wird die Abwärme die zum
Beispiel in der Industrie oder bei
Müllverbrennungsanlagen entsteht gezielt
als Wärmeenergie genutzt
klassische Win-Win-Situation für die wir
jedoch ebenso wie für die Geothermie das
Fernwärmenetz noch deutlich ausbauen
müssen das sind unterirdische Leitungen
die die Wärmeenergie in Form von heißem
Wasser zu den Haushalten und teilweise
auch Produktionsanlagen bringen
besonders in Ballungsgebieten und im
Umland von wärmeintensiven
Industrieanlagen versteckt sich hier ein
großes Energiepotenzial aber egal woher
wir unsere Wärmeenergie beziehen in
jedem Fall müssen wir unsere Gebäude
deutlich besser isolieren und
energetisch effizient gestalten denn
aktuell verlieren wir an dieser Stelle
derart viel Energie wenn wir das über
Biomasse Geothermie und elektrifizierte
Wärmeproduktion Decken wollen würde die
Energiewende deutlich teurer
elektrifizierte Wärmeproduktion das
klingt sperrig aber da drin steckt
tatsächlich was wichtiges in Zukunft
wird man Strom und Wärme nicht mehr ganz
getrennt voneinander denken können
ebenso wenig wie Verkehr und Strom oder
Industrie und Strom das Zauberwort heißt
sektorenkopplung hinter diesem super
sexy Begriff versteckt sich unter
anderem folgende Idee Strom soll immer
mehr und mehr von den Aufgaben
übernehmen die früher das verheizen von
Gas das Verbrennen von Kohle und das
Verfahren von Erdöl erledigt haben was
uns zurück zu unseren alten Bekannten
voller unbekannter Überraschungen bringt
Wind und Solar also legen wir los die
Umstellung der Stromerzeugung auf
erneuerbare Energiequellen
[Musik]
hier seht ihr den Ausbau der
Energieträger solar- und Wind in den
letzten Jahren man würde hier jetzt
wahrscheinlich einen konstanten
Aufwärtstrend erwarten den gibt es aber
nicht die Gründe dafür sind vielfältig
Gesetzesänderungen förderungszuschüsse
Preise und vor allem Prioritäten von
Gesellschaft Politik und Unternehmen und
jetzt kommt eine traurige Wahrheit und
wenn ihr sonst aus diesem superlangen
Video nichts mitnehmt dann bitte
zumindest das der tatsächliche Ausbau
von erneuerbaren Energien hat wenig mit
dem technisch Machbaren zu tun sondern
vor allem mit politischen
gesellschaftlichen juristischen und
wirtschaftlichen Gründen
[Musik]
aktuell ist das Ziel der Bundesregierung
bis 2030 80 Prozent von Deutschlands
Strombedarf aus Erneuerbaren zu decken
dafür muss die Umstellung jetzt aber so
schnell wie möglich gehen denn um den
Plan einzuhalten muss ich der
erneuerbare Strom in nur acht Jahren
fast verdoppeln wie um alles in der Welt
sollen wir das hinbekommen
[Musik]
so jetzt brauchen wir nur noch Formular
a135b und dann haben wir es auch schon
fangen wir mal ganz am Anfang an bei den
Genehmigungen bevor nämlich irgendetwas
irgendwo in Deutschland gebaut werden
darf muss es natürlich genehmigt werden
und das ist schon mal ziemlich
kompliziert häufig dürfen die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger dann noch
Einspruch einlegen wenn sie etwas gegen
das Bauvorhaben einzuwenden haben und
wie ihr euch wahrscheinlich denken könnt
passiert das vor allem bei einer Sache
sehr häufig bei Windrädern um euch mal
eine Vorstellung davon zu geben was
häufig heißt 2020 wurden in Deutschland
766 neue Windräder an Land genehmigt im
gleichen Zeitraum wurden 512 abgelehnt
oder zurückgenommen warum am häufigsten
wurden planungsrechtliche Gründe genannt
ebenso wie vom Antragsteller
zurückgezogene Pläne
artenschutzrechtliche Gründe eine
fehlende Zustimmung der Gemeinde und der
Naturschutz im Schnitt dauert es hier im
Land der Bürokratie fünf bis zehn Jahre
bis ein Windrad geplant und genehmigt
ist und dann wurde es ja noch gar nicht
gebaut geschweige denn ans genau
aufgenommen das soll mit dem Energie
sofortmaßnahmenpaket nun schneller gehen
auch sehr sexy Name das neue Gesetz soll
unter anderem die Genehmigung
erleichtern und nimmt auch Einfluss auf
die Rechtsprechung denn ist deklariert
den Ausbau der erneuerbaren Energien als
Gegenstand überragenden öffentlichen
Interesse ist und Element nationaler
Sicherheit und das ist rechtlich
ziemlich relevant denn es gibt dem Bau
solche Anlagen Vorrang in der
sogenannten
schutzgüterabwägung das heißt wenn ein
Ministerium oder ein Gericht zum
Beispiel abwägen muss ob es die
Vogelwelt in einem Wald schützen oder
den Bau eines Windrades erlauben soll
bekommt das Windrad durch dieses neue
Gesetz Vorrang zumindest vor anderen
nationalen Gesetzen denn die
Vogelschutzrichtlinie der EU steht immer
noch höher als das nationale Gesetz
wenn die Gerichte die Energiewende auch
hier priorisieren wollen müssten sie mit
der nationalen Sicherheit argumentieren
und ob das funktioniert das muss
tatsächlich erst noch vor einem Gericht
in einem Präzedenzfall geklärt werden
meiner Meinung nach wäre es auf jeden
Fall zu begrüßen wenn Gerichtsverfahren
so schneller entschieden werden könnten
denn gegen 24 Prozent denn 2020
genehmigten neuen windleistungen wurden
anschließend Klagen eingereicht kein
Wunder dass es so nicht vorangeht in
Deutschland
[Musik]
wie politisch korrekt ist das Fachkräfte
in dasselbe Kapitel zu nehmen wie
Rohstoffe so unser Windrad und unsere
Solaranlage sind jetzt also genehmigt
als nächstes brauchen wir die
entsprechenden Rohstoffe dafür ebenso
wie die Arbeitskräfte die das ganze
bauen und installieren dass das ein
Problem werden könnte weil es jeder der
in letzter Zeit mal versucht hat einen
Handwerker zu bekommen oder die Bauteile
die der Handwerker verbauen soll und
auch in den Verwaltungen fiel das an
Personal dass die Genehmigungsanträge
halbwegs zeitnah bearbeiten könnte das
beantwortet aber auch schon indirekt die
Frage ob wir durch die Energiewende
Arbeitsplätze verlieren auf die Frage
gibt es nämlich ausnahmsweise mal eine
klare Antwort nein im Gegenteil
forschende der University of British
Columbia in Kanada ermittelten dass wir
durch die Energiewende bis 2050 weltweit
wahrscheinlich fast 8 Millionen neue
Stellen bekommen werden ihr sucht also
einen neuen Beruf wie wäre es mit etwas
in der Erneuerbaren Branche
kommen wir zu den Rohstoffen die wir ja
brauchen um unsere ganzen erneuerbaren
Energieanlagen zu bauen bei den
sogenannten waver-basierten Solarmodulen
die in Deutschland am häufigsten
eingesetzt werden gibt es in absehbarer
Zeit keine rohstoffknappheiten am
kritischsten wäre Silber das aber
weitestgehend durch Kupfer ersetzt
werden könnte einige Hersteller
schwenken hier bereits um bei der
Herstellung der Solarzellen selber gibt
es aber einen Haken wir sind aktuell
sehr abhängig vor allem von China was
machen wir wenn sagen wir mal China zum
Beispiel in Taiwan einmarschiert und wir
uns aussuchen können ob wir es
sanktionieren und keine
Photovoltaikanlagen mehr bekommen oder
die Invasion einfach so tolerieren ich
denke daher wir brauchen eine eigene
Produktion von Solarzellen in der EU die
politischen und wirtschaftlichen Für und
Wieder sprengen den Rahmen dieses Videos
aber es sei hier an der Stelle zumindest
einmal angemerkt die Alternativen zu
erneuerbaren Energiequellen sind jedoch
nicht besser wir machen uns bei Kohle Öl
Gas und Kernelementen zum Beispiel
ebenso abhängig von anderen Ländern von
denen nicht alle naja wie drücke ich das
am Besten aus von denen nicht alle so
besonders nett sind bei Kernelementen
sind wir sogar zu 100% abhängig also
alles nicht zu ideal aber immerhin kann
man die Teile eines Solarpanels oder
eines Windrades recyceln und
wiederverwenden dazu haben wir übrigens
in ein paar Minuten ein fact Check-In
für euch was da nun wirklich geht und
was nicht Kohle Öl und Gas oder Uran
kann man auf jeden Fall nicht recyceln
apropos wo wir gerade bei ungewollten
Nebeneffekten sind wie ist das jetzt
eigentlich mit Infraschall bei
Windrädern und den Vögeln werden die da
nicht geschreddert
davon habt ihr bestimmt schon mal gehört
Leute argumentieren bei Windrädern
entstehen sehr viel
gesundheitsschädlicher Infraschall wir
haben natürlich auch das für euch
recherchiert und waren direkt doppelt
überrascht denn die Studie von 2004 die
immer als Quelle angegeben wird ist
nicht nur längst offiziell als falsch
entlarvt worden sie hat auch nie den
Gesundheitseffekt von Windräder
Infraschall untersucht aber fangen wir
erstmal am Anfang an die Bundesanstalt
für Geowissenschaften und Rohstoffe BGR
die die besagte Studie damals
durchgeführt hat das Teil des
kernwaffentest-stopp-vertrags das heißt
sie überwachen mit extrem empfindlichen
Messgeräten ob seismische oder
Infraschallwellen auftreten die darauf
hinweisen dass eine Nation eine
Atomwaffe getestet hat eine dieser
Stationen steht in der Antarktis und
eine im Bayerischen Wald jetzt wäre es
natürlich blöd wenn die BGR einen
Atomwaffentest meldet obwohl in Wahrheit
einfach nur ein neues Windrad in der
Nähe in Betrieb sagen ist das heißt Sie
müssen deren Infraschall aus den
Signalen herausrechnen und dafür müssen
sie natürlich erst einmal wissen wie
viel davon überhaupt verursacht wird die
Wissenschaftler zogen also mit ihren
Messgeräten los und veröffentlichten
2004 ihre Ergebnisse in einer Studie
leider hatten sie sich bei der
Umrechnung in Dezibel verrechnet um das
10.000 fache 10.000 kein Witz und leider
fiel das ganze auf 15 Jahre lang
niemandem auf und selbst als es auch
viel und man die BGR damit konfrontierte
dauerte es mehr als ein Jahr bis die
Anstalt ihren Fehler öffentlich zugab
zahlreiche Windkraftgegner gingen mit
dieser Studie gegen geplante Windräder
vor zahlreiche Gemeinden entschieden
sich aufgrund von gesundheitlichen
Bedenken gegen den Bau einer Anlage und
das alles wegen eines rechenfehlers
soviel dazu mittlerweile hat sich sogar
Peter Altmaier dem die Behörde damals
Unterstand entschuldigt tatsächlich
produziert ein Windrad nicht mehr
Infraschall als normaler Straßenverkehr
und ob unhörbar tiefen Schallwellen
überhaupt gesundheitsschädlich sind
selbst wenn sie noch so stark wären weiß
die Wissenschaft noch überhaupt nicht
wenn ja müssten wir aber noch deutlich
mehr als nur Windräder abschaffen und
ich habe noch ein Mythos für euch den
wir uns angesehen haben diese Sachen mit
den Vögeln wir können hier bestätigen
was ihr bestimmt auch schon anderswo
gehört habt es sterben deutlich mehr
Vögel im Straßenverkehr oder am
Glasscheiben als am Windrädern ja
Windräder töten Vögel das steht fest wie
viele das sind da kursieren einige
Zahlen die relativ weit auseinander
gehen nach langer Prüfung und Recherche
sind wir aber genau wie diese Studie
hier zu dem Ergebnis gekommen dass alle
Schätzungen
mehr oder weniger Bullshit sind es gibt
hier keine belastbaren Zahlen was auch
nicht wirklich verwundert die Erhebung
wäre extrem teuer sich Wissenschaftler
müssten an unzähligen Orten in
Deutschland über einen langen Zeitraum
tote Vögel unter Windrädern zählen denn
man kann die Zahl von einem Windrad auch
nicht exemplarisch hochrechnen je nach
Jahreszeit und Standort des Windrades
gibt es dort unterschiedlich viele Vögel
unterschiedlich viele Vogelarten
unterschiedlich viele Zugvögel Routen
ihr versteht das und all das beeinflusst
wie viele Vögel nun an einem speziellen
Windrad zugrunde gehen trotzdem ist es
natürlich schade um jeden einzelnen
Vogel daher arbeiten Forscher zum
Beispiel an abschaltmechanismen wenn
sich ein Vogel nähert eine zweite
Bemühung ist die Betroffenen Vögel und
Regionen näher einzugrenzen eine Studie
unter anderem vom Max-Planck-Institut
für Verhaltensbiologie in Konstanz
untersucht hierfür auf welchen
Flugrouten Vögel besonders betroffen
sind die Idee ist dass man in diesen
Gebieten einfach weniger Windräder baut
oder abschaltanlagen verpflichtend
dennoch gilt Klimaschutz und Artenschutz
werden in dieser Debatte ein bisschen
gegeneinander ausgespielt und das ist
nicht wirklich zielführend denn was
feststeht der Klimawandel ist ein
weitaus größeres Problem für Vögel als
windtrainer
der nächste Punkt den man beim Bau von
erneuerbaren Anlagen bedenken muss ist
der Energieaufwand für die Produktion
man hört ja manchmal besonders über
Solarpanels Design sehr
ressourcenintensiv das würde sich für
den Umweltschutz überhaupt nicht lohnen
okay schauen wir uns mal die Fakten an
die Zeit die eine Anlage braucht um die
Energie zu erzeugen die man für ihren
Bau eingesetzt hat heißt Energie
Rücklaufzeit diese liegt laut mehreren
Studien die ihr hier alle selber
nachlesen könnt bei Solaranlagen in
Europa aktuell zwischen 0,9 bis 2,1
Jahren danach rechnet sich ein Panel
bereits wenn es um Energieaufwand geht
und diese Zahl singt übrigens stetig
denn die Herstellung wird mit der Zeit
immer Ressourcen sparen da und die
Panels immer effizienter Fazit also da
die meisten Solarpanels derzeit ungefähr
30 Jahre leben lohnt sich der Aufwand
energetisch gesprochen auf jeden Fall
bei Windkraftanlagen liegt diese
energierücklaufzeit je nach Standort bei
zwei Monaten bis zu einem Jahr bei einer
Lebensdauer von ca 20 Jahren bei
Standorten mit weniger Wind kann die
Energie Rücklaufzeit auch etwas länger
sein im Vergleich zu fossilen
Kraftwerken gewinnen sämtliche
erneuerbaren Energien also Haus hoch
denn fossile können schon vom
Grundkonzept her ihre aufgewendete
Energie nie wieder ganz reinholen sie
verbrauchen ja tagtäglich neue auch hier
gibt es also von unserer Seite aus ein
klares erneuerbare Energien lohnen sich
energetisch gesprochen okay jetzt stehen
die Anlagen und produzieren fröhlich
Strom wir hatten es aber vorhin schon
erwähnt die Anlagen liefern nicht immer
gleich viel Energie in Abhängigkeit vom
Wind und der Sonne steht uns mal mehr
und mal weniger davon zur Verfügung
liefert beides längere Zeit Menge
Energie sprechen besonders die Gegner
gerne vom Szenario der dunkelflaute
[Applaus]
ist die wirklich geben und wenn ja was
machen wir dann
nun wie soll ich sagen es ist großartig
dass wir in Deutschland sind denn die
zumindest meistens sonnigen Sommer und
stürmischen Winter gleichen sich mehr
oder weniger aus dennoch muss man sagen
eine dunkelflaute ist möglich und wird
es wohl auch hin und wieder geben der
Deutsche Wetterdienst hat es konkret in
Zahlen zusammengefasst die letzten Jahre
zeigen dass es im Durchschnitt zweimal
pro Jahr je zwei Tage gegeben hat an
denen wir weniger Wind und Sonnenenergie
hatten als der erwartbare Mittelwert
manchmal können diese Phasen auch länger
dauern und auch im Tagesverlauf werden
wir gerade bei Sonnenenergie natürlich
zusätzlich häufig das Problem haben dass
wir tagsüber Strom haben und abends
Strom brauchen ist die Energiewende also
vielleicht doch keine so gute Idee führt
sie zu ständigen Blackouts nein denn
dunkelflaute heißt nicht automatisch
Blackout die Wissenschaft kennt alleine
fünf große Hebel mit denen wir ein paar
Tage dunkelflaute genauso wie die
Stromschwankungen im Tagesverlauf
ausgleichen können
Nummer eins die offensichtlichste Lösung
ist einfach weniger verbrauchen einfach
ist natürlich einfach gesagt aber
tatsächlich sowohl machbar als auch
wahrscheinlich ich habe es ja am Anfang
schon mal angeteasert dieser große und
mega wichtige Punkt über unseren eigenen
Verbrauch kommt ganz am Schluss Nummer
zwei ist die Stromproduktion einfach
zeitlich zu verteilen eine gute
Möglichkeit für Solarstrom ist
beispielsweise wenn man die Panels nicht
nur nach Süden ausrichtet sondern auch
nach Osten und Westen natürlich liefern
diese Ost- und westpanels insgesamt
weniger Strom dafür können sie aber die
Randzeiten des Tages besser bedienen
Idealfall kann ein Panel sogar im
Tagesverlauf mit der Sonne mitwandern
auch der Neigungswinkel eines
Solarmoduls hat einen Einfluss darauf
wie optimales im Sommer oder Winter
Strom produzieren kann
hier haben wir also schon mal viele
Stellschrauben über das Jahr gesehen
kommt es natürlich zusätzlich auf den
richtigen Mix aus Wind und Solarenergie
an um die Schwankungen zu überbrücken
Lösung Nummer 3 sind Speicher die
Möglichkeiten hier sind zahlreich wir
haben uns in der Recherche allein neun
verschiedene Speichertypen angesehen sie
alle haben vor und nachteile gemessen an
ihrem Preis ihrer Speicherkapazität
ihrer Lebensdauer ihrem CO2 Verbrauch
und vor allem ihrem Wirkungsgrad der
gibt an wie viel von der Energie die wir
rein tun um sie zu speichern am Ende
auch wieder rauskommt
Lithium-Ionen-Batterien schneiden in
diesem Rennen mit 70 bis 90%
beispielsweise sehr gut ab und im
privaten Haushalten mit Solarpanels
leisten sie auch bereits gute Dienste um
die Tagesenergie um zu verteilen dafür
sind die Speichermengen im Vergleich zu
beispielsweise pumpwasserspeichern eher
gering ebenso wie die Lebensdauer der
Batterien
insgesamt scheinen punktwasserspeicher
der beste Kompromiss zu sein zumindest
zum Speichern für einige Tage wenn die
ganze Welt Norwegen wäre dann hätten wir
vermutlich gar keinen Speicherproblem
allerdings können wir in Deutschland
davon nur sehr wenige bauen weil uns die
entsprechende Geographie fehlt außerdem
werden die Wassermengen die wir in
Deutschland haben aufgrund des
Klimawandels immer ungleichmäßiger
werden für punktwasserspeicher
problematisch schauen wir uns also das
Thema Speicher einmal genauer an bevor
wir mit Lösungen 4 und 5 weitermachen
letzten Endes wird es für uns in
Deutschland wahrscheinlich ein Speicher
Mix werden da gibt es einmal den
Lastenausgleich über Stromnetz dazu
kommen wir gleich noch mal dann brauchen
wir Kurzzeitspeicher wie Batterien für
die Mittagssonne die abends unsere
Glühbirne betreiben sollen und
Langzeitspeicher wie chemische Stoffe
als saisonale Speicher diese chemischen
Speicher zu denen auch Wasserstoff
gehört haben auch noch einen weiteren
Vorteil sie können in all den Bereichen
eingesetzt werden die nicht einfach
elektrifiziert werden können in der
Industrie gibt es zum Beispiel einige
und auch im Verkehrssektor werden
Flugzeuge und Schiffe so vermuten einige
paper darauf angewiesen sein denn wir
können leider nicht an einfach alles
einen Stecker machen und auch wenn wir
das jetzt hier verhältnismäßig kurz
abhandeln diese chemischen Speicher für
alles was nicht mit Strom laufen kann
sind ein super wichtiger Baustein für
das Gelingen der Energiewende einer der
Gründe warum trotz seiner Ineffizienz an
Wasserstoff festgehalten wird so viel
Speicherkapazität aufzubauen ist
natürlich extrem teuer dafür gibt es
einen Hoffnungsträger der die Kosten
reduzieren könnte und das sind die
Batterien von E-Autos sie haben gleich
mehrere Vorteile sie sind bereits
vorhanden und müssen nicht erst für viel
Geld aufgebaut werden sie haben viel
Kapazität meistens bereits mehr als
heimspeicher und sie sind räumlich weit
verteilt denn wenn ich in Hamburg gerade
zu viel Strom habe wollen ordentlich
Seewind geht dann hilft es mir nicht
wenn in Stuttgart gerade
Speicherkapazitäten frei sind denn dann
müsste ich Energie ja erstmal über das
Übertragungsnetz von Hamburg nach
Stuttgart leiten was das Netz in dem
Moment enorm belasten würde Speicher
müssen also auch räumlich entsprechend
verteilt werden und genau das sind
unsere Autos noch können die wenigsten
von ihnen ihre Batterien dem Netz zur
Verfügung stellen Teslas können das zum
Beispiel nicht für die kommenden
Generationen ist diese Technologie aber
teilweise in Planung und ihr müsst euch
übrigens keine Sorgen machen dass ihr
morgens aus dem Haus geht und euer Akku
leer ist und ihr nirgendwo hinfahren
könnt ihr könntet zum Beispiel einfach
blocken dass ihr jeden Morgen um 8 Uhr
mindestens mal genug Energie für die 50
Kilometer zur Arbeit in eurem Auto
braucht also fassen wir zusammen
Schätzungen sagen dass wir insgesamt
etwa 11 Terawattstunden Speicher
brauchen werden 2020 hatten wir
0,00116 Terawattstunden an Batterie
speichern und immerhin 0,04
Terawattstunden an Pumpspeicher also
fehlt echt nur noch ein klitzekleines
bisschen das ist aber kurzfristig gar
nicht so schlimm viele forschende sagen
dass ich das Speich Potenzial
automatisch entwickeln wird sobald mehr
Strom da ist der gespeichert werden muss
sprich sobald es sich wirtschaftlich
rechnen Speicher zu betreiben es sei
ganz natürlich dass noch niemand in
Speicher investiert wenn kaum Speicher
gebraucht werden
Überschüsse lassen sich auch erstmal
noch über den ebenfalls notwendigen
Netzausbau ausgleichen zudem ganz
zentralen Punkt der Wirtschaftlichkeit
kommen wir auch gleich noch mal erst
müssen wir aber unser
dunkelflottenproblem zu Ende lösen
[Musik]
eine vierte Lösungsmöglichkeit für das
dunkelflottenproblem sind herkömmliche
Kraftwerke die man bei Bedarf einfach
zuschalten kann
Gaskraftwerke eignen sich hierfür am
besten dass sie relativ schnell rauf und
wieder runtergefahren werden können
außerdem können sie im Laufe der Jahre
auf Speicherstoffe wie Wasserstoff oder
Biogas umsteigen so dass sie irgendwann
auch ganz erneuerbar laufen können eine
Studie des Fraunhofer ISE schätzt dass
die installierte Leistung hier zwischen
100 und 150 Gigawatt liegen sollte also
wahrscheinlich ein bisschen weniger als
Windenergie an Land liefert die fünfte
Lösungsmöglichkeit des dunkelflauten
Problems heißt Lastenausgleich und ist
so simpel wie genial wir versuchen nicht
nur umständlich die strohmmenge an
unseren Bedarf anzupassen wir machen
zusätzlich genau das Gegenteil wir
passen unseren Bedarf an die Strommenge
an hui ich hoffe ihr hattet noch etwas
durch denn dieses Video hier ist noch
nicht vorbei aber wie wäre es denn mit
ein paar praktischen Tipps wie ihr jetzt
direkt Strom sparen könnt vielleicht
habt ihr euch im Angesicht der Energie
auch schon mal intensiver mit
Stromanbietern auseinandergesetzt oder
vielleicht auch schon überlegt wo und
wie ihr konkret sparen könnt denn
aktuell sind die Preise ja wirklich
extrem gestiegen Problem in Deutschland
die meisten Stromverträge haben
Fixpreise und selbst wenn der Strom für
euren Anbieter günstiger wird für euch
bleibt er gleich teuer der Sponsor
dieses Videos Tipper hat aber genau
dafür eine Lösung denn Tipper gibt euch
den aktuellen Preis den der Strom gerade
an der Börse kostet weiter das schwankt
natürlich jeden Tag und sogar jede
Stunde und in der Tipper App bekommt ihr
das auch ganz kompakt angezeigt und
wisst dann wann Strom gerade besonders
günstig oder eben teuer ist seht ihr zum
Beispiel mittags um zwei dass der Strom
gerade besonders günstig ist dann haut
ihr einfach direkt die spül- und
Waschmaschine an und spart sofort Geld
und wenn ihr das regelmäßig macht dann
kommt da schon so einiges zusammen und
die hilft auch noch der Netzstabilität
weil ihr Strom dann nutzt wenn er gerade
verfügbar ist dafür bietet Tipper dann
eigene Gadgets wie den stromtracker
Parts an mit dem man genau sieht wie
viel man verbraucht und dadurch
Verdienste aber übrigens sein Geld nicht
mit dem Strom den sie euch verkaufen
sondern mit den Gadgets wenn ihr
richtige stromprofis werden wollt dann
könnt ihr eure Geräte sogar per Smart
Hub verbinden und den Prozess mit der
Waschmaschine von eben sogar komplett
automatisieren klingt gut jetzt kommt
das Beste wenn Ihr Strom dann kauft wenn
er besonders günstig ist dann ist ja
sogar gleich effizienter und
nachhaltiger denn der Strom ist immer
dann besonders günstig wenn gerade
besonders viel aus erneuerbaren Quellen
zur Verfügung steht hierfür werden
nämlich keine CO2-Zertifikate benötigt
falls ihr also direkt Einfluss auf euren
Strompreis haben wollt und sicher gehen
wollt dass er auch aus erneuerbaren
Quellen kommt dann schaut mal bei Tipper
vorbei und gebt den Code Watson ein der
Wechsel dauert nur 5 Minuten und in der
App findet ihr alle Infos zum effektiven
Strom sparen und falls euch das noch zu
umständlich ist könnt ihr innerhalb von
zwei Wochen einfach wieder kündigen
jetzt mal ehrlich wenn meine
Waschmaschine automatisch mittags laufen
würde anstatt abends dann würde das für
mich ja keinen Unterschied machen wenn
das sogar ganz gut dann muss ich nämlich
nicht abends immer wach bleiben bis die
endlich fertig ist für meine Nachbarn
wird das wahrscheinlich auch ganz gut
denn das würde die nicht am Einschlafen
hindern wenn gerade der Schleudergang
durchgeht nach zum elf oder wenn mein
Auto die ganze Nacht durch immer mal
wieder so ein bisschen lädt anstatt mit
einer vollen Leistung die ersten zwei
Stunden nach dem Anschließen zu laden
das wäre mir auch ziemlich egal solange
es am nächsten Morgen fertig ist und ist
sogar besser für den Akku ähnliche
zeitlich flexible Prozesse sind auch für
die Industrie interessant das
Fraunhofer-Institut schätzt das private
Haushalte um die 20 Gigawatt flexibel
verbrauchen könnten und die Industrie
bis zu 14 Gigawatt das sind immerhin
4,8% von für 2030 prognostizierten
gesamtstrombedarf also ein mega
interessantes Potenzial damit der Markt
den Lastenausgleich auch wirklich in
Praxis umsetzt braucht es aber Anreize
beispielsweise ein mit Angebot und
Nachfrage schwankender Strompreis klar
wenn Strom mittags nur die Hälfte kostet
stelle ich meine Spülmaschine auch gerne
dann an und für die von euch die gerade
zum zweiten Mal schon denken dass sie
mittags doch auf der oder in der Uni
sind Unternehmen und die Forschung
entwickeln bereits IT-Lösungen die das
nach meinen voreingestellten wünschen
automatisch steuern dann könnte ich
morgens die Maschine vorladen und ihr
sagen liebe Spülmaschine ich komme um 18
Uhr wieder nach Hause bitte spür doch an
der Zwischenzeit mein Geschirr am besten
zu dem Zeitpunkt wo es am günstigsten
ist aber auf jeden Fall bis 18 Uhr da
muss es fertig sein und wenn sie sich
dann auch noch von alleine ausräumen
würde dann hätte wahrscheinlich niemand
mehr etwas gegen die Energiewende
einzuwenden aktuell gibt es diese
finanziellen Anreize für den
Lastenausgleich aber noch nicht Dinge
wie der mered Order Effekt Regulierungen
Gesetze Umlagen und vieles vieles mehr
stehen dem noch im Weg hinzu kommt dass
der Strommarkt wahnsinnig komplex ist
wusstet ihr zum Beispiel dass die
aktuell hohen Strompreise gar nicht
hauptsächlich Putins schuld sind sondern
Frankreichs und warum der married order
Effekt die Energiewende ausbremst das
Thema ist so groß komplex und vor allem
wichtig dass wir uns entschieden haben
dass jetzt nicht hier als kleinen
Unterpunkt abzuhandeln sondern ein
eigenes Video daraus zu machen und das
gibt's in drei Wochen am 27 November
hier auf dem Kanal also abonniert gerne
dr Watson um das nicht zu verpassen für
dieses Video hier sei einfach gesagt der
Gesetzgeber hat ganz viele
Stellschrauben um die Energiewende für
Investoren lukrativ zu machen und da
waren sich alle Experten mit denen wir
gesprochen haben einig an denen muss
auch geschraubt werden denn wenn die
Wände sich für die Unternehmen nicht
rechnet wird das alles nichts ebenso
wichtig ist übrigens auch ein starker
CO2-Preis hierzu ist das ausführliche
Video übrigens schon online und das
findet ihr hier ein Energiemarkt der je
nach Angebot und Nachfrage ständig
Energie hin und her verkauft reduziert
unseren Speicherbedarf erhöht aber in
gewissem Maße die jetzt Schwankungen
damit das funktioniert braucht es ein
entsprechendes Stromnetz was uns zum
nächsten Kapitel bringt vorher aber noch
das Fazit zu unserer dunkelflaute sie
ist kein Problem dass wir nicht lösen
können mit mehr Effizienz speichern
Lastenausgleich flexibler
Stromproduktion und Gaskraftwerken
sollte hier in Deutschland eigentlich
keine dunkelfl zum Blackout führen und
weiter geht's
lustig oder ich dachte man braucht
einfach nur ein paar Kabel mehr aber ich
hätte nicht gedacht dass das Mega
Komplex wird denn der Strom muss ja
jetzt noch irgendwie zu uns nach Hause
kommen über Stromnetz klar da gibt es
aber aktuell zwei Probleme zum einen
wachsen die Strommengen die wir
transportieren müssen die Windenergie
von der Küste muss in den Süden und die
Solarenergie aus dem Süden muss in den
Norden hierfür brauchen wir mehr
Kapazitäten als wir aktuell haben das
andere Problem sind die Schwankungen bei
der verfügbaren Strommenge wir hatten es
schon
Ausgleichsmöglichkeiten gibt es viele
aber dafür muss das Netz diese auch
handeln können denn für ein
funktionierendes Stromnetz müssen wir
immer in etwa so viel Strom einspeisen
wie wir gerade verbrauchen sowohl zu
viel als auch zu wenig Produktion kann
kaskadeneffekte verursachen die das Netz
zum Kollabieren bringen diese
Grundeigenschaft wird bleiben auch wenn
wir auf erneuerbare Energien umstellen
daher muss das Netz diese Schwankungen
flexibel in Sekundenschnelle ausgleichen
können
zusätzlich zum Ausbau des Stromnetzes
empfehlen forschende daher eine starke
lokale Vernetzung der Akteure unser Büro
hier ist zum Beispiel das beste Beispiel
oben über uns wohnen Leute wir hier sind
eine Firma wir haben auch Solarpanels
auf dem Dach und wenn es jetzt noch
einen heimspeicher im Keller gäbe
könnten unsere Nachbarn und wir
untereinander schon mal unseren
Strombedarf ausgleichen wir brauchen ihn
tagsüber jetzt gerade die aber eher
abends die Schwankungen die unser
Energieverbund dann noch ans Netz abgibt
sind deutlich geringer als wenn wir
beide separat mit dem Netz interagieren
würden und das kann man jetzt immer und
immer größer Denken in immer größeren
Netzwerken denn natürlich kann das
gesamtdeutsche Übertragungsnetz nicht
mit jedem einzelnen Haushalt
kommunizieren
forschende vermuten daher dass
Aggregatoren ein Modell sein könnten die
das wirtschaftlich machen sie könnten
mehrere kleine flexible Stromverbraucher
wie uns und unsere Nachbarn
zusammenschließen und unsere
Flexibilität dem großen Netz als
Dienstleistung anbieten so etwas
ähnliches wird zum Beispiel in Augsburg
bereits getestet und ich habe hier dazu
schon mal ein Video gemacht
[Musik]
so oder so brauchen wir aber tatsächlich
auch einfach viel mehr stromnetzkabel
das Projekt Netzausbau wurde daher
bereits von der Bundesregierung
gestartet und immer wieder aktualisiert
die letzte Aktualisierung war im Januar
und die ist durch die klimagesetznovelle
bereits wieder veraltet die neuen Zahlen
gibt es aber leider erst 2023 da ja hier
die von Januar weitere
6.350 Kilometer im Übertragungsnetz sind
im Netzentwicklungsplan zusätzlich bis
2035 vorgesehen so weit geht die
aktuelle Planung als Vergleich mit 6.350
km könnte man sieben Mal Deutschland von
Nord nach Süd durch spannen und am Ende
noch eine Schleife dranbinden da haben
wir also noch gut was zu tun
als Zwischenfazit können wir hier also
jetzt schon mal sagen es gibt noch viel
zu tun aber die technischen
Möglichkeiten um unser komplettes
Energiesystem auf erneuerbare
umzustellen gibt es wir haben die
erneuerbaren Energieanlagen wir haben
das entsprechende Netz und wir haben
alle möglichen Stellschrauben um immer
genug Energie zur Verfügung zu haben
zwei Aspekte fehlen jetzt aber noch für
ein komplettes Bild die große Frage was
uns die Energiewende kosten wird und das
Recycling
[Musik]
forschende erwarten in den kommenden
Jahren immer größere Mengen an
Solarpanels die ausgedient haben und
entsorgt werden laut EU-Recht müssen
diese zu 80% recycelt werden und diese
Recyclingrate wird auch erreicht also
alles super leider nein denn die Sache
hat einen Haken viele Recycling nur das
Glas und Aluminium die den Großteil des
Panels ausmachen aber die wirklich
interessanten Stoffe wie Silber und
Kupfer werden trotzdem extrem stark
gedowns cycle sprich verranscht zum
Beispiel als beigemisch von Straßenbelag
warum ein Experte hat uns gesagt dass
sich der Mehraufwand beim Recycling
wirtschaftlich gesprochen einfach noch
nicht lohnt die Technologie um alte
Solarpanels besser zu recyceln gibt es
aber durchaus schon forschende vermuten
dass es erst eine verlässliche Menge an
alten Panels und die entsprechenden
gesetzlichen Vorgaben geben muss damit
die Technik auch großflächig in der
Praxis umgesetzt wird
außerdem könnte eine modulare Bauweise
helfen sprich die Panels von Anfang an
schon so zu bauen dass sie leicht am
Ende auseinanderzunehmen sind die
Forschung arbeitet an verschiedenen
Ideen doch auch hier der Aufwand den
ganzen Herstellungsprozess auf die neue
Bauweise umzustellen rechnet sich
einfach noch nicht wie sieht das mit
giftigen Stoffen bei Solarpanels aus da
war doch was oder in 90% der gängigen
Solarpanels ist Blei verarbeitet hierbei
handelt es sich aber jeweils nur um
wenige Gramm zusätzlich kommt in einigen
wenigen Solarpanels Cadmium vor und das
betrachten wir hier nicht mehr weil die
fast gar nicht in Deutschland eingesetzt
werden dann gibt es noch
Fluorverbindungen und antimonen die
ebenfalls in manchen solarpanel-typen
verarbeitet werden sie alle sind giftig
jetzt ist aber die interessante Frage
kommen Sie da auch wieder raus und im
allgemeinen lautet die Antwort nein
nicht wenn die Solarpanels einfach 30
Jahre lang auf der Wiese rumstehen aber
wenn ich das Glas zerschlage und in
einer starken sauren oder basischen
Umgebung lange liegen lasse ja dann kann
es schon sein dass Blei sich langsam
löst in Deutschland passiert sowas quasi
nicht da die alten Panels eingesammelt
werden müssen in anderen Ländern wo sie
auf Deponien landen kann das aber
durchaus der Fall sein bei Antimon dass
ich im Glas befindet ist es ähnlich
auch Flur ist giftig und kommt in
verschiedenen Verbindungen aus der
Rückseitenfolie heraus wenn man sie
verbrennt daher haben die
Verbrennungsanlagen entsprechende
Luftfilter so dass der fluoridhaltige
raucht die Fabrik nicht verlässt diese
Stoffe sind für uns also erstmal nicht
gefährlich solange wir nicht mit ihnen
in Berührung kommen trotzdem sollte man
den Einsatz von giftigen Stoffen
natürlich so gut es geht generell
vermeiden die Forschung arbeitet daher
daran all diese Stoffe zu ersetzen und
es ist auch in den meisten Fällen
technisch möglich doch ohne gesetzliche
Vorgaben hatte die Industrie bisher
wenig Anreize auf die neuen Verfahren
umzustellen das haben uns die Experten
gesagt mit denen wir gesprochen haben
für das Blei haben sich die
lobby-vertreter der Industrie sogar
extra eine Ausnahmeregelung erkämpft
denn in Elektrogeräten darf eigentlich
gar kein Blei mehr drin sein eigentlich
hinzu kommt mit unserem deutschen
Recyclingverfahren Schaden uns die
giftigen Stoffe nicht doch es gibt da
eine seltsame Auffälligkeit forschende
mit denen wir gesprochen haben haben
bemerkt dass nicht so viele alte
Solarmodule beim Recycling auftauchen
dort Berechnungen eigentlich sein
müssten vermutlich wird die Differenz
vor allem in östliche Länder exportiert
die deutlich geringere
recyclingstandards haben als wir wenn
die alten Module dort auf Deponien
landen ist das für die Menschen dort
durchaus gefährlich die Wissenschaftler
mit denen wir gesprochen haben wollen
daher den Export von gebrauchten Modulen
auf Länder begrenzen die ordnungsgemäßes
Recycling garantieren bei Windrädern
sehen die recyclingprobleme übrigens
generell ähnlich aus der Großteil wird
in Deutschland recycelt bei einigen
Verbundstoffen ist das aber schwierig
auch hier sind es noch zu wenige als
dass ich gute Standards etablieren und
auch hier gilt wieder wie bei den
Solarpanels den speichern und noch so
viele mehr dass sich leider alles
irgendwie wirtschaftlich rechnen muss
auch hier gibt es wieder ein Henne und
ei-problem was uns zu unserem letzten
Kapitel bringt den Kosten
[Musik]
die ganze Energiewende kostet natürlich
zunächst erstmal Geld der erneuerbare
Strom selbst ist in der Produktion unter
den meisten Bedingungen aber günstiger
als fossile Energie insbesondere der
Solarstrom bei Windenergie hängt es so
ein bisschen vom Standort ab rechnet man
zu den stromproduktionskosten den
sogenannten Strom Gestehungskosten jetzt
noch die externen Kosten in Form von
Klima und Gesundheitsschäden und
Ewigkeitskosten in Form von zum Beispiel
endlagerungen hinzu gewinnen die
erneuerbaren Energien auf voller Länge
zusätzlich gehen vorschnitte davon aus
dass der Preis für die erneuerbare
Stromproduktion immer weiter fallen wird
was aber Geld kostet ist der Weg dahin
beim Umbau der Infrastruktur wie den
Netzen und speichern fallen natürlich
extra Kosten an die irgendwie bezahlt
werden müssen das Interessante ist hier
aber je mehr wir alle an einem Strang
ziehen desto günstiger wird die
Energiewende das Fraunhofer ISE hat
beispielsweise ausgerechnet dass die
Wände im Szenario Suffizienz also einer
potenziellen Zukunft in der alle
mitmachen und ihren eigenen
Energiebedarf senken und 440 Milliarden
Euro kosten wird das klingt erstmal viel
aber wenn wir annehmen dass dieses Geld
verteilt auf die Jahre 2020 bis 2045
ausgegeben wird also zwischen dem
Entstehungsjahr der Studie und dem Jahr
wo wir klimaneutral sein wollen sind das
nur noch 17,6 Milliarden Euro pro Jahr
das ist weniger als die Hälfte von
unserem rüstungsgefahr 2021 und davon
muss man jetzt noch die Kosten abziehen
die unser jetziges Energiesystem im
gleichen Zeitraum gekostet hätte und
wenn man dann noch die Kosten
gegenrechnet die der Klimawandel
andernfalls verursachen würde dann wird
das Ganze sogar richtig lukrativ
wenn wir hingegen versuchen mal
abgesehen von mehr Windanlagen
Solarmodulen und Co genauso weiter zu
leben wie bisher dann könnt ihr die
Energiewende rund 2,3 Billionen Euro
kosten also mehr als das Fünffache
apropos das Fünffache dieses Video hier
gerade hat ungefähr das Fünffache an
Zeit Energie und eben auch Geld
verschlungen wenn ihr also uns und
unsere unabhängige journalistische
Arbeit unterstützen wollt dann tut das
gerne auf patreon da könnt ihr zum
Beispiel Videos früher vor allen anderen
gucken oder auch Livestreams explosiv
mit mir gucken und wir freuen uns
wirklich sehr über die monatliche
Unterstützung mit der wir rechnen können
auf der anderen Seite wenn ihr uns nur
einmalig unterstützen wollt auch das
geht jetzt ganz frisch haben wir ein
Spendenkonto eröffnet unter dem wir uns
unterstützen könnt wir freuen uns
wirklich sehr über jeden Betrag der da
ankommt danke schön von uns
[Musik]
was mich zu meinem letzten Punkt führt
uns wir haben es ja ganz am Anfang schon
mal erwähnt dass wir immer weniger
Ressourcen brauchen werden das ist
leider kein Naturgesetz sondern dafür
braucht es uns ihr könnt euch das in
gewisser Weise wie eine Wippe vorstellen
je weniger wir verzichten desto mehr
erneuerbare Energien brauchen wir
umgekehrt können wir ganz viele
Ressourcen und Geld für erneuerbare
Energien sparen je mehr wir verzichten
die eben genannte Studie mit den Kosten
beweist das jetzt habe ich es gesagt das
Böse v-wort Verzicht und bevor jetzt
irgendwer ruft links grün Fehlanzeige
selbst Friedrich Merz Chef der CDU hat
im Angesicht der nach unserer aktuellen
Zählung 7 aktiven globalen Krise dem
Ukraine Krieg anerkannt wir haben
wahrscheinlich jedenfalls für eine
gewisse Zeit den Höhepunkt unseres
Wohlstandes hinter uns was ich bei
unserer aktuellen Definition von
Wohlstand ungefähr mit weniger Konsum
übersetzen lässt
in diesem Einsatz steckt übrigens auch
schon ein Teil der Lösung wer sagt denn
dass man viel Wohlstand hat nur weil man
viele Dinge hat was ist denn mit dem
Wert einer wirklich guten Freundschaft
oder dem Gefühl von Glück dass man hat
wenn man viel Freizeit hat was Wohlstand
ist wird von Gesellschaft zu
Gesellschaft anders definiert und kann
sich im Verlaufe der Zeit auch verändern
jetzt heißt es aber erstmal Verzicht auf
Dinge und Möglichkeiten an deren Besitz
für uns gewöhnt haben alles andere wäre
auch irgendwie komisch oder wie
verzichten für alles mögliche wenn wir
etwas wollen auf Schokolade für die
Traumfigur aufs Kino wenn wir gerade auf
etwas hinsparen auf unseren Putzplan für
den wg-frieden alles hat seinen Preis
und die Rettung unserer Zivilisation vor
der größten globalen Katastrophe seit
dem Aussterben der Dinosaurier soll
keinen Preis haben
[Musik]
diese letzten beiden Kapitel des Videos
sind übrigens nicht nur meine eigene
Meinung wen das mehr interessiert der
kann gerne mal in irgendeinen
ipc-bericht reingucken ist eigentlich
egal in welchem die sagen alle das
Gleiche aber ich hatte euch ja noch eine
gute Neuigkeit versprochen unsere Welt
wird sich ändern es hört sich irgendwie
gruselig an ich weiß eigentlich ist es
aber gar nicht so schlimm denn unsere
Welt hat sich schon mehrmals grundlegend
verändert bei der Industrialisierung zum
Beispiel oder seit der Erfindung des
Internets aber irgendwie geht es immer
weiter darauf dürfen wir vertrauen und
wir dürfen sogar wählen wie soll unsere
veränderte Welt aussehen wir können uns
Lokal engagieren und gucken was unser
Dorf oder unser Stadtteil zur
Energiewende beitragen kann Windräder
wollen wir nicht okay aber vielleicht
ein Fernwärmenetz
Solarpanels kann ich nicht so einfach
aufs Dach bauen weil ich in einer
Mietwohnung wohne okay aber vielleicht
kann ich ja häufiger Fahrrad fahren wenn
wir nicht wählen bekommen wir jedoch
einfach vor die Füße geknallt was der
Klimawandel so für uns in petto hat und
das wird ziemlich heftig der vergangene
Sommer war dagegen nur ein allererster
Warmlauf des Klimas
die Energiewende erzeugt zwar keine
komplette CO2 Neutralität dafür müssen
auch andere Akteure wie zum Beispiel die
Landwirtschaft einiges umstellen aber
sie ist ein riesiger Schritt in diese
Richtung daher jetzt endlich
abschließend die große Frage die Frage
aller Fragen
ist die Energiewende machbar das haben
wir alle Forschenden gefragt mit denen
wir bei der Recherche für dieses Video
hier gesprochen haben und hier sind ihre
Antworten in der Reihenfolge in der wir
sie ihnen gestellt haben in den
Interviews lese vor ja ja
auf jeden Fall und ja
okay da herrscht also schon mal ziemlich
offensichtlich Einigkeit ist sie auch
bis 2045 machbar aber unsere nächste
Frage technisch machbar ja die größten
trägheiten sind dort wo wir Gesetze und
Regularien ändern müssen sie muss
machbar sein und die letzte Frage die
wir allen gestellt haben ist ist die
Energiewende machbar wenn wir so
weitermachen wie bisher nö wir brauchen
mehr Flächen für PV mehr Standorte für
Windräder Nord südleitungen und eine
pv-produktion in der EU nein das muss
schneller gehen mit mehr Schmackes und
Begeisterung und weniger Bedenkenträgern
also in Kurzform ja die Energiewende ist
machbar aber wir müssen mehr Tempo an
den Tag legen wir müssen die Flächen für
Wind und Solar bereitstellen mehr
Speicher installieren einen flexibleren
Strommarkt etablieren und auch als
Verbraucher flexibler und sparsamer
werden wir müssen mehr alternative
Wärmequellen erschließen und die Strom-
und Fernwärmenetze ausbauen und die
Industrie muss auf Strom und chemische
Speicher umstellen wir brauchen einen
höheren zwei Preis isolierte Häuser
vernünftiges Recycling und ganz ganz
viel Forschung und vor allem müssen wir
alle an einem Strang ziehen denn dann
könnte die Energiewende unser Freiticket
in eine Welt werden in der wir weniger
Ressourcen verbrauchen aber trotzdem
verdammt gut leben in diesem Sinne
bleibt hoffnungsvoll wir rocken das
vielen Dank fürs zuschauen und an dieser
Stelle auch noch mal ein riesengroßes
Dankeschön an alle Wissenschaftlerinnen
und Wissenschaftler die an diesem Skript
hier als Beratung als faktenchecker oder
für Recherche Gespräche mitgewirkt haben
ohne euch hätten wir so ein krasses
Video nicht schaffen können ganz ganz
großer Dank geht auch an Carolin
Riethmüller die dieses Video hier zu
einem ganz großen Teil geschrieben hat
vielen vielen Dank danke euch fürs
zuschauen wir sehen uns beim nächsten
Mal wieder bleibt neugierig euer Cedric